[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody thank you for being here
I'm really excited to talk to you and
I'm gonna get started just by
introducing myself my name is Max and
I'm a developer and I'm an artist and my
day job is that I'm like a user
experience engineer and that basically
means that I'm an engineer and I build
things but it's always very directly
informed by the way that the user
perceives it and by the effect that it
has on them and their perceptions I also
really love websites particularly
websites that are maybe like useless or
weird I just think those are kind of
like the most fun thing that you can
build on a computer so I'm talking today
about like sand simulations and also
about building interactive experiences
with web assembly and I have to level
with you before we start but this talk
is a little bit of like a Trojan horse
situation so i lured you all into these
stands with the promise of information
about exciting emerging web technology
like web assembly but I'm really just
going to talk to you about my favorite
thing which are falling sand games so I
hope that's not a problem so if you
haven't heard of falling sand games they
are kind of this whole genre of web game
there's like free flash applet kind of
things and where they work is that
you've got a palette of like pixelated
elements that you can paint onto the
screen and they all behave according to
different kind of like physical
phenomenon so there's fire and water and
you get to paint with them and then they
interact with each other and cool things
happen they share a lot in common with
cellular autonomy and things like
Conway's Game of Life and in particular
they have the same kind of really cool
behavior where you have very simple
rules and when you let those play out
you get really amazing complex emergent
behavior
and it can be really surprising to even
the person maybe who set up those rules
and certainly the person watching them
play out because you could never expect
exactly what you would get just based on
reading that it does this in these
conditions or that it's much more
complex another thing I really love
about sand games is that they really
like have a very low fidelity visual
representation of what's happening on
screen like you have a couple of colored
pixels maybe they're moving around a
little bit but there's such little there
to go off that it really lets your
imagination run wild and interpret what
you're seeing with its own like layer
over what's going on and so you see
something much more vivid in your mind's
eye than what's going on on screen and
there's a lot of room to play with that
and I think that's really fun so many
people oftentimes ask when they see when
these games is like how do you win this
game and there is no wind condition or
score or anything like that the way
these games work is that you're making
your own objectives as you play and
that's part of the game and so
oftentimes that means understanding
what's going on in front of you so maybe
you're trying to figure out how a new
element works or how it interacts with
another one you might make a hypothesis
but what will happen I then make an
experiment and test it out and see what
happens
or maybe you will be like telling
yourself a story and playing it out with
the elements in front of you and seeing
what happens and imagine your mind and
so on and so I think they're really it's
really wonderful mode of play and it's
one where you're not only the player but
you're also kind of a storyteller for
yourself and you're almost kind of like
a game maker for yourself because you're
using this toy and playing with it the
way that you want to play with it so my
favorite falling a sand game has been
around for a long time and it's Dan ball
JP it's called the powder game and it
kind of has this really interesting
feature which is that when you make
things in it
right in the game in the menu you can
upload them and they go to a server and
other people can browse them and see
them and it's kind of got this like
long-standing weird and thriving
community of people building interesting
things and uploading them for each other
and it's really cool to see given like
just these small tools the kind of
things people make for each other to
play with so you've got like your
bog-standard
is thousands and thousands of volcanoes
you know it's like an infinite fourth
grade science fair of different
volcanoes people make but volcanoes are
cool I can see what they want to make a
lot of volcanoes people make different
like destructible structures so you can
load it into your browser and then have
fun setting it on fire or pouring acid
on it and that's like a fun way to play
with somebody who you've never met a but
people get really creative like there's
all kinds of games people make out of
the simple elements they have including
things like mood rings and so you can
see that this one says like it's very
clear that it will not be accurate of
your mood unless you first vote there's
lots of like vote pandering in these
communities it's it's a staple of how
they communicate but this is a cool game
that somebody made inside of another
game my personal favorite type of sand
game upload is this entire genre called
don't smoke where it it kind of displays
to you the anatomical phenomenons that
will occur if you smoke a cigarette in
this case the lava will like travel up
your brainstem and explode your brain so
these games are really awesome and you
can see why I was fascinated with them
like for my entire childhood and so as I
got a little older and when I first
learned to program as soon as I could
like rub two four loops together I knew
that what I wanted to build was like a
falling sand game but you know it would
be the best one ever obviously but so I
knew a little JavaScript and I knew how
to use a canvas API and I started trying
to look at other falling sand games and
understand how they were working and
what
the elements were doing when they were
moving around and when I was
reimplemented them I found their really
simple and with just a couple like very
low numbers of hundreds of lines of
JavaScript I suddenly had like water
moving around the security and I was
really excited and I was having so much
fun but I realized that as I kept adding
new elements to the game it was getting
slower and slower and I didn't have a
very firm grasp on concepts such as like
functions or having your code in more
than one file and with I was manifesting
is that as I was adding more features
into this big glob of code everything
was getting more and more bug-eaters
taking longer and so you can see this
blob on the right-hand side of the
screen is an element that was just a
mistake I made that I decided to
domesticate and keep in the game as the
glitch element because I thought it was
cool but I wanted to keep building this
but it was getting kind of untenable and
I couldn't understand what's going on
anymore
and so I was like okay I don't have to
do I have to refactor this code somehow
and make it good I didn't know what the
exact what that meant but I you know I
needed to be in different files so I had
to set up web pack so I could have
different files in my JavaScript project
and then this is the last commit I ever
made to the project it doesn't fifteen
set it up to use webpack for my
impending refactor which never never
happened I think this is kind of a
common story so some time went by and I
got a cat I moved to California but
other things were going on in my life
but I was still kind of thinking about
sand games and I was also noticing a lot
of really cool projects that were
happening that were letting people build
and code in the browser and kind of make
program one element of a larger system I
thought those are really cool and so I
had this idea that I got really excited
about last year which is what if there
was a falling sand game where people
could code their own elements and upload
them and then all those elements could
have AI different people can interact
and there could be reactions that nobody
ever anticipated and something could
happen so I kind of knew that I needed a
different architecture diagram for my
game than just having everything in one
file in one blob like the people are
going to be writing
to plug into here there would need to be
some sort of separation and to like an
engine and then maybe the different
elements and I was maybe inspired by
things like react and I thought that
okay there can be an API that they talk
over and it can be the framework and
then the components but I also knew that
if I want people to actually code and
upload their own elements it would need
to be like a pleasant and easy
experience I don't need to handle as
many of the edge cases I could for them
and so I was really so I started to
prototype this and I was really trying
at all times to move as much of the
gross logic out of the elements and make
them as easy and fun to make and make
the engine if that had to be gross that
was fine so I was really happy with this
prototype and I was having so much fun
building elements in it like it was just
me building them but I was having a
great time and I thought this I wanted
to keep doing it and want to show people
but I was building in Lua and if I know
anything about if you want someone to
use your thing it's kind of got to be on
the web as far as I'm concerned and so I
wanted to start over and build it so
that I could actually share with people
so that kind of turned into sand spiel
and you can play online a Stansfield
club the rest of my talk is kind of
boring so if you want to do that for the
next ten minutes like I'm not going to
judge you
so I'll but I'll give you a quick demo
so you can kind of see what it looks
like so I'll press play you've got your
different elements I'll plant like some
flowers and then I think that inevitably
and Stansfield people tend to just like
set everything on fire but it's okay it
doesn't release any carbon so that's
kinda what the game looks like and you
can see there's this canvas where the
simulation is happening then there's
also the buttons in the UI so the one of
the things that I found when I was
building sans peel it turned out to be
really critical and really helped me
build it was I decided to try to use web
assembly and so there is actually
webassembly content of this talk I'm
sorry
and I've said that we're at a couple
times now maybe you've heard it this
week but just to like rehash webassembly
is not really a language it's a like
instruction format that you compile of
languages too and it has some properties
that people are kind of excited about so
first of all is that it's fast so I'm
not going to go into detail here because
this is kind of an any kind of
performance conversation as a nuanced
conversation but particularly it is you
can if you have a lot of it's very
predictable what the performance will be
with JavaScript you can make it fast but
you are relying on the way that it gets
optimized I need to write in a very
careful way whereas with webassembly
there's much less moving pieces and if
you write it a certain way you'll know
it'll be fast on everybody's browser
another important aspect of web assembly
is that it's sandboxed so it is safe and
web assembly to run code written by
someone who you don't necessarily trust
on your machine or even on your users
machine sometimes and it's not going to
like steal their passwords necessarily
because it's it's sandbox they can't
reach into the rest of the system like
some native code can I thought this was
going to be a really important thing for
my game because I thought I was gonna be
running people's like code they wrote
and running and other people's computers
but it turns out I never actually got to
that part that was the lamp vicious but
may in the future this will be coming
handy but just the other effectors of
webassembly we're still really useful to
me and so lastly I just want to let
people know that it really is ready to
use I was kind of surprised with this
myself but you know like for major
browsers and some other ones as well
have already implemented it it works
also like on mobile really well and I
was I'm surprised by how fast it's
moving and I think that part of it is
that the spec is very pragmatic and it's
very informed by what browsers already
have as far as infrastructure and
there's a lot of buy-in for it and so
it's very rapidly becoming something you
can ship and I had no problems with
compatibility surprisingly with web
assembly
one more thing about it being ready to
use is that the tooling is at least in
my experience was really good so I wrote
some rest code for a sans peel that was
compiled to web assembly and the entire
tool chain that I use to do that
including some tools like Waze and PAC
and wise I'm buying gen which let you
respectively compile rest code into web
assembly file and also a JavaScript file
that kind of loads it and then lazon by
and Jen is a tool for kind of calling in
between from web assembly and JavaScript
these tools are they're still like in
beta but they're really nice to use and
there's a lot of shared culture and like
shared communication norms within the
JavaScript community and like the rust
and webassembly community so if you have
expectations about how a library should
work and how the documentation should be
and like what kind of error messages
should give you that you are used to
from reading JavaScript and you can go
try to write rust and webassembly you're
not going to be like shocked and
horrified because it's a lot of the same
people and they take they have the same
expectations you do of how what a good
user her face is for a tool so this was
really great and I really appreciate
think I'll use this another really
critical thing about that I want to tell
you about the way that you can use web
assembly is that you don't have to like
write your whole application in it and
then it just happens to run in the
browser but it's really just a big hunk
of rust or something my app is about 50%
JavaScript and about 50% rust or
webassembly
and this was awesome because I got to
put the things that needed to run many
many many times a second and be really
fast I got to write that in rust and
make it fast and then all the things
that don't need to be fast because it's
just like you know building the user
interface or triggering a network
request all those things to go through
it in JavaScript and benefit a from just
the fact that javascript is really good
at doing these things and be that I got
to use the whole ecosystem of react and
different tools made this really awesome
and if I had tried to write the whole
thing in rust would have taken me a lot
longer because I would have been like
there's no really good tools right now
for
building interfaces yet not like the way
there are in JavaScript and so being
able to split my concerns here was
really awesome so I think you can kind
of imagine like the the JavaScript code
here is mostly just you know react code
like you may have seen before and the
way it interacts with the code that I
wrote rust is that essentially there is
a JavaScript like class that has some
functions and those happen to be backed
by web assembly but from the perspective
the JavaScript you're just calling
JavaScript functions and so I can do
things like I have a paint method which
will draw a circle on to the screen in a
certain element in a certain radius or I
have one to reset the canvas or to
calculate one ticket the simulation and
so from the JavaScript perspective
you're really just calling some methods
and it happens to be implement web
assembly and be fast and that's thanks
to some of these tools that I mentioned
before like what hasn't been Gen so as
for the what the web assembly code looks
like this tick method which runs one
frameless emulation I'll kind of show
how it works it's pretty simple and this
is by the way what powers this part of
the game where the pixels are moving
around and interacting so essentially I
have a data structure which is just like
a big two-dimensional array of all the
data for my different cells of the grid
and it goes through loops through each
one in order and when it gets to each
one it runs an update function based on
whatever the type is of the grid cell
and so you get to the third one and it's
a sand grid it's a piece of sand so it
matches to the sand update function and
the sand update function is really
simple it's really just like an if-else
statement and the way that works is that
it looks at its local coordinate system
and so it says okay what's the cell
below me what's that was the type of
that if it's empty then I can fall down
and I'll just go down there and I'll
erase myself and write myself one pixel
lower alternatively if that first check
failed and maybe there's like a piece of
stone underneath you then it goes to the
second statement
it checks one of the diagonals and tries
to fall there and does the same thing so
that's all there is to this algorithm
that lets you do the sand and kind of
the trick here is that it's happening on
every pixel of the grid and it's
happening at 60 frames per second and it
starts to look like how you would
imagine sand would work so there is like
18 other elements and there's some of
them are a little more complicated but
they all have the same pattern of
they're a single function they call some
api's to read their neighbors and to
write to their neighbors and then you
get different behavior so I mentioned
this earlier but it really was like the
key to being able to make this project
quickly the fact that I could put things
in webassembly
that needed to be fast and I could
implement everything else in JavaScript
and use the ecosystem and not have to
worry about all the type checking and
all of the like other conditions that
rust and forced on your code that can
sometimes slow you down and so another
thing I mentioned that there's Network
code
and the network code is that I actually
also built a like an upload and download
functionality like and the sandy and I
really liked and so this has been like
the most gratifying part of the project
so a lot of it's pretty much middle
schoolers but a lot of middle schoolers
play this game and they draw really
amazing things like they kind of
actually ignore the fact that there's a
simulation attached and just use it like
mspaint
but I guess it's like not blocked in
their school or their computer lab so
that's maybe why they use it but they
draw really awesome stuff and it's
really fun to see what they do and I
think that like maybe one of the so the
most popular there's like an up voting
system and the most liked and loved post
on Sam spiel of all time is this puppy
Juno Luna I can't explain it but I also
loved you know Luna so there's all kinds
of fan art and people remix things una
Luna and drawing her in different
situations on the right that's super
Doudna Luna the tall one and
I guess that one difference between Sam
spiel and the powder game is that the
powder game there was a rule against
loading somebody else's submission and
re-uploading it or modifying it and Sam
still doesn't enforce that we kind of
like encourage for King and I think
that's what leads to some of this fun
like doing Aluna stuff
unfortunately I mentioned that the best
part of the project has been seeing the
things people upload so that's also been
definitely the worst part of the project
so not everybody is nice and there's
like I moderate the post over the the
website every morning and waking up to
it is not always fun sometimes I feel
like this person where I feel like these
people are ruining the game and I wish
they had never been created so none of
it would happen and so I do do some
manual moderation but it's really not
sustainable and I'm not sure what to do
and so I've kind of like looked to where
I look for to solve problems when I have
programming problems and they've not
been useful like there's no algorithm
for making it would be nice to it for
making people be nice to each other on
the Internet
not even like string matching algorithms
work I tried and like nor do other
places where who have usually solved my
like tough programming problems like CSS
tricks they have no button style that
will make people be nice to each other
unfortunately so this is a problem I
still have I haven't solved it and I
know that there's my people have
problems like this and I'm definitely
curious to hear what they did or if
they're just like there's all this
invisible work that's happening behind
the scenes that makes it look like
things are nice so I definitely
interested to talk if you think you know
a solution just like please do not tell
me to use a neural network thank you
so please do I think we have a break
after this so please play this and spiel
if you you know wanna kill some time
chill out and I have a longer form blog
post that goes into a little bit more of
the inspiration for the game and some of
the design decisions and also into some
of the technical details because I
glossed over some things and thank you
so much
[Applause]
[Music]